saloum quel beau symbole de trinquer
avec ce qui a rapproché champlitte et le
mexique le vin des familles parti
s'installer il ya 200 euros pour trouver
l'eldorado et des histoires incroyables
même deux siècles plus tard sarah là
haut saônoise a rencontré là-bas eduardo
son futur époux une drôle de rencontre
je pense est effectivement rester un
petit temps et rentrer en france mais
j'ai rencontré eduardo au mexique avec
qui je me suis marié et qui s'avère être
un descendant des français de champlitte
qui sont partis s'installer là bas de
cette union est née une petite file ici
un clin d'oeil à la maman de jean
christophe de marc ce prêtre qui a mis à
jour l'histoire de cette diaspora haut
saônoise parties à plus de 9000 km il
est à l'origine de ces échanges entre
l'état de veracruz et la haute-saône et
surtout champlitte il est décédé en
février la délégation mexicaine a tenu à
lui rendre hommage c'est très fort et
particulièrement d'être ici et payer non
respect aux
êtres démarre pas ce qui est juste pas
si vous savez noté tout le monde a fait
messi silence le musée de champlitte
retrace cette histoire forte et la
haute-saône aimerait aller plus loin
dans cette histoire de coeur avec cette
étape cousant de pratiquement 9 millions
d'habitants ces échanges ils ont
toujours été forcément très culturelle
mais on va justement essayer de
développer aussi un petit peu peut-être
l'aspect touristique également allier
culture et patrimoine avec les mexicains
mais maintenant on est en train de
préparer des voyages et spéciale pour
les personnes et qui habite à haute
saône qui vont à
connaître aurait connaître et en parts
de berkous des liens renforcés culturel
et économique d'autres projets sont dans
les cartons et la haute-saône ira son
tour rendre visite à ses amis mexicains
sa grande famille
si quelques mots